This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。欢迎收看“Look Back at It”播客。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是Sam J.。我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
您正在收听的是由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games为您带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间关注黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，这份特定的检测报告是你篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改了一次检测报告。互联网侦探们动用了大批人马，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼（Michael Ranjini）。我的脑子都炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, welcome back to the show, new listeners, old listeners, it's so wonderful to have you here. Thank you so much for tuning in for a really exciting episode. So fun, career anxiety, and we absolutely stoked.
大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们在20年代面临的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及这些变化对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目，新听友们，老听友们，很高兴能在这里见到你们。非常感谢大家收听这期非常精彩的节目。太有趣了，职业焦虑，我们绝对兴奋极了。
No, in all seriousness, it is actually one of my favorites. I know I say that every time, but every time I get the opportunity to really dive into a topic like this, especially one that is relevant to my life, which is what I always try and do is find something that I can personally relate to. It is just such a valuable experience. So that was the case with this episode. And before we get into the content, I just want to thank everyone who has subscribed recently. I've gotten a lot of new paid subscribers as well. For those of you who don't know about this option, I publish one exclusive episode every month. It's normally about an
不，说真的，这其实是我的最爱之一。我知道每次我都这么说，但每当我有机会深入探讨这样一个话题时，尤其是与我的生活相关的话题——这也是我一直在努力做的，就是找到我能产生个人共鸣的东西——这真是一次太宝贵的经历了。这期节目就是这样。在进入正题之前，我只想感谢最近订阅的所有人。我也收到了很多新的付费订阅者。对于那些还不知道这个选项的人，我每个月会发布一期独家节目。它通常大约
hour long and it's more of a chatty episode. Maybe you really like when you hear people talking to their friends about what's going on in their life or getting a special guest on or answering your questions. That's kind of the content that I like to put out there. So if you haven't already, it would be amazing if you checked it out, no pressure. Just if you really love the show, it's a really easy way to support me and let me continue doing what I love. I've also recorded this intro about seven times today because I'm all over the place. I'm all over the place. So please excuse me if I mumble and jumble my words. I hope you can forgive me this one time because it's been a long day. But we're here to talk about work. We're here to talk
长达一个小时，是一期更像闲聊的节目。也许你真的很喜欢听人们和朋友谈论他们生活中的近况，或者邀请特别嘉宾，亦或是回答你的问题。这正是我喜欢发布的那种内容。所以如果你还没看的话，去看看就太棒了，没有任何压力。如果你真的很喜欢这个节目，这是一个非常简单的方法来支持我，让我能够继续做我热爱的事情。我今天已经录了七次这个开场白了，因为我的思绪太乱了。我的思绪太乱了。所以如果我口齿不清、语无伦次，请大家原谅我。希望大家能原谅我这一次，因为今天实在太漫长了。但我们是来聊聊工作的。我们是来聊聊
about what it feels like when we're not succeeding, what it feels like when we feel like we're behind. I think we've all experienced this sense of anxiety to do with our work and to do with our careers and how we make money. It is a terrible feeling, that sense of anxiety. So definitely something I think is incredibly valuable to discuss on a podcast that is focused in our 20s. And during this decade, so many of us are starting our first jobs or entering into our careers. So this feeling of unease is definitely one that I would expect of many of us to have perhaps already experienced or to experience one day. And I also just think since most of our, you know, I think most of us spend a great deal of
当我们没有成功时的感受，以及当我们觉得自己落后时的感受。我想我们都体验过这种与工作、职业以及我们如何赚钱相关的焦虑感。那种焦虑感真是一种糟糕的体验。所以这绝对是一个我认为在以20年代为主题的播客中讨论极其有价值的话题。在这个十年里，我们中的许多人正在开始第一份工作或进入职场。因此，这种不安的感觉肯定是我们中的许多人已经经历过或终有一天会经历的。而且我也认为，既然我们的大多数人，你知道，我认为我们大多数人都花费了大量的
our lives working or at work, it's. It's really inevitable that it will play a pretty key role in shaping our levels of happiness and our overall psychology and sense of well-being. And maybe you're listening to this today and you feel like you're not at the point you should be. You should be more ahead or have some idea of what you want to do. Maybe your career isn't fulfilling. You could be doing more, something you love more, something that lights your fire. Perhaps you're stuck in a bit of a rut.
生命在工作或职场中，它……它在塑造我们的幸福水平、整体心理以及幸福感方面，发挥着相当关键的作用，这是不可避免的。也许你今天在听这个节目，觉得自己还没有达到应有的水平。你本该取得更大的进展，或者对想做什么有一些想法。也许你的职业并不能带给你成就感。你本可以做更多的事情，做你更热爱的事，做点能点燃你激情的事。也许你有点陷入了刻板的生活或工作模式中，
your productivity levels are at an all-time low or you've reached a dead-end and you're feeling really stuck or like a bit of a failure at what you're doing whether you're currently working or studying towards a dream career or job and you're just not sure if it's what really motivates you this is what that episode is really trying to nail down. I think there are so many ways we can feel like the career and professional aspects of our lives and our aspirations are not what they should be and are causing us unease or anxiety, fear, unnecessary worry, especially in this day and age. The opportunities for our professional and working lives are seemingly endless. So how do we know that we're pursuing the right path and doing what we actually love to do? There are so many
你的生产力降到了历史最低点，或者你遇到了死胡同，感觉自己真的卡住了，或者在做的事情上觉得自己有点像个失败者，无论你目前是在工作还是在为梦想中的职业或工作而学习，却不确定这是否真的是你的动力所在，这正是这期节目真正想要探讨的。我认为有很多方式让我们觉得生活中的职业和专业方面以及我们的追求没有达到应有的状态，并给我们带来了不安、焦虑、恐惧、不必要的担忧，尤其是在当今时代。我们职业和工作生活的机遇似乎是无穷无尽的。那么我们如何知道自己正在追求正确的道路，并且在做我们真正热爱的事情呢？今天有太多的
points of comparison today for what we should be doing, what others are doing, and how we might be falling behind, you know, perceiving ourselves as failures or feeling super lost. So if this is you, hopefully we can dispel some of that anxiety today and remind ourselves collectively, all of you listening right now, that life is long, life is more than work, and there are opportunities in your future that I think none of us could ever fathom and it will surprise you and allow you to live your dream life, maybe even better than your dream life. And above all, we're going to talk about the psychology behind feeling anxious when it comes to what are we actually doing. What does our job mean for us? What is it about work and our careers that can be such a sensitive and difficult topic?
对比点让我们去思考我们应该做什么，别人在做什么，以及我们是如何落后的，你知道，觉得自己是失败者或者感到超级迷失。所以如果这就是你，希望我们今天能消除一些焦虑，并共同提醒自己——所有现在正在收听的你们——生活很长，生活不仅仅只有工作，你的未来充满了我们谁也无法想象的机会，它会给你带来惊喜，让你过上梦想中的生活，甚至比你梦想中的生活还要好。最重要的是，我们将讨论当我们在思考“我们到底在做什么”时感到焦虑背后的心理学。我们的工作对我们意味着什么？工作和职业的哪些特质会让我们如此敏感和难以应对？
And why is it that our 20s? I really do believe our 20s are so important for dispelling career anxiety and creating a really healthy foundation for a balanced work life. So very excited to jump into it. And thank you again for tuning in. So personally and from personal experience, I think it is really easy for us to get caught up in social comparison when it comes to our careers and when it comes to our working lives. It's, I think comparison in general is a huge killer of joy and especially when it's linked to things like our professional capacity and our dreams and our career and working motivations, it can really make us feel quite awful and quite unsettled. There is a really amazing theory to explain this, to explain why perhaps you today are looking
为什么说20年代……我真的相信我们的20年代对于消除职业焦虑以及为一个平衡的工作生活建立真正健康的根基是如此重要。所以非常高兴能深入探讨这个话题。再次感谢大家的收听。所以，就个人而言，根据我自己的经验，我认为在我们的职业生涯和工作生活中，我们真的很容易陷入社会比较。我认为，比较通常是快乐的巨大杀手，尤其是当它与我们的专业能力、梦想、职业和工作动机等事情联系在一起时，真的会让我们感觉相当糟糕和心神不定。有一个非常惊人的理论可以解释这一点，解释为什么也许今天的你正在环顾
around, looking at people you graduated with, looking at people in your cohort, looking at people you work with, that your friends and feeling like everyone else seems to be really happy with where they are and I'm not. And this theory that explains us so perfectly is social comparison theory. And it suggests that people value their own personal and social and professional worth by assessing how they compare to others, by having a look around and almost doing a quick equation or, you know, some quick math about, am I here? head here? Am I winning? Am I losing? What are other people doing that I'm not? And like I said, that's such a killer of joy, especially in our working lives because there is this sense of
四周，看着与你一起毕业的人，看着你同龄人中的人，看着与你共事的人、你的朋友，觉得其他人似乎对自己的现状都很满意，而我却没有。这个完美解释这一现象的理论就是社会比较理论。它表明，人们通过评估自己与他人的对比，通过环顾四周并几乎做一个快速的等式，或者进行一些快速的计算来衡量他们自己的个人、社会和职业价值，比如：我是不是落后了？我是不是领先了？我是不是在赢？我是不是在输？别人在做什么而我没有做？正如我所说，这真是快乐的巨大杀手，尤其是在我们的工作生活中，因为这里存在着一种
competition, there is this sense of acceleration and a hierarchy. And I think that that social comparison is only being elevated and only becoming more severe by the creation of social media for our professional lives. I know, you know, LinkedIn is a, I think, a huge. culprit in this more frequent and more prevalent sense of unease when it comes to our working capacity. You know, now people have the opportunity to not just show the highlight real of their social lives and the highlight real of their day-to-day lives, but also all the things that they're achieving, all the things that they're doing and curate that on like a public resume.
竞争感、加速感和等级制度。而且我认为，随着为我们职业生活而创建的社交媒体的出现，这种社会比较只会不断加剧，变得更加严重。我知道，你知道，领英（LinkedIn）是一个巨大的罪魁祸首，它让人们在面对工作能力时，更频繁、更普遍地产生这种不安感。你知道，现在人们有机会不仅展示他们社交生活的精彩集锦和日常生活的精彩集锦，还可以展示他们取得的所有成就、所做的所有事情，并将其精心策划在一个公开的简历上。
And I think if you have LinkedIn, maybe you have this experience of checking up on people that you may have gone to high school with or people you met at uni or people who are in a similar career path to you and having that feeling of like oh my god i am nowhere where they are i have no idea what i'm doing how did they land such a fabulous job they seem so happy they seem to have so much success and that is social comparison to a tea we don't look at ourselves as singular beings we don't appreciate our own accomplishments we have to kind of assess them in regards to others. And I really think that there is this kind of sense of expectation that we have to have it all together, especially when we're young. And I remember I went
我想如果你有领英，你可能有过这样的经历：查看那些和你一起上过高中、在大学认识的或者走着跟你类似职业道路的人的近况，然后产生那种“天哪，我完全比不上他们，我根本不知道自己在做什么，他们是怎么找到这么棒的工作的，他们看起来那么快乐，看起来取得了那么巨大的成功”的感觉。这就是典型的社会比较。我们不会把单体自己看作独立的个体，我们不欣赏自己的成就，我们不得不通过与他人进行比较来评估它们。我真的认为存在着一种期望，即我们必须把一切都安排得井井有条，尤其是在我们年轻的时候。我记得我走进
into my final year of uni with no internships. I wasn't obviously working a job that I loved. And I had this feeling like the career I'd always wanted, you know, working in politics or as a journalist. It wasn't really feeding my ambition and everyone around me seemed to have these massive goals and these incredible opportunities and I couldn't grasp on to anything that felt permanent or meaningful in my life, especially in my career or in the professional sense of the world. And it was an awful feeling. I think it can be especially hard for those of us who have always been high achievers, always gotten really great grades, been slightly ahead of the curve and that social comparison where we're looking around and seeing people doing amazing things
大学最后一年时没有任何实习经历。我显然没有做一份我热爱的工作。我有一种感觉，我一直想要的职业——你知道的，在政界工作或成为一名记者——并不能真正滋养我的野心，我身边每个人似乎都有宏大的目标和难以置信的机会，而我却无法抓住生活中任何感觉永久或有意义的东西，尤其是在我的职业生涯或世界的工作层面上。这是一种糟糕的感觉。我想这对于我们这些一直以来都是优等生、总是能取得好成绩、稍微领先于时代的人来说尤其困难，那种社会比较——我们环顾四周，看到别人在做惊人的事情——
can be quite deadly and really undercut that sense of personal accomplishment. But there were some really important lessons I learned during that time. Firstly, absolutely everyone is faking it. I'm promising you, no one really knows what they're doing with their career or where their aspirations are going to take them, especially in our 20s. Our 20s are about learning and making mistakes. It's the golden decade, the forgotten decade, the wayward decade, where you're actually allowed to quit, you're allowed to fail, you're allowed to try new things.
可能会相当致命，并真正削弱那种个人成就感。但我在那个时期学到了一些非常重要的首先，绝对每个人都在假装。我向你保证，没有人真正知道自己的职业生涯在做什么，或者他们的追求会把他们带向何方，尤其是在我们的20年代。我们的20年代是关于学习和犯错的。它是黄金十年，是被遗忘的十年，是任性的十年，在这个十年里，你其实是被允许辞职的，你被允许失败，你被允许尝试新事物。
Anyone who's not doing that is faking it. Honestly, I really do believe that. And secondly, so many of the decisions we make concerning our careers and our jobs and our professional lives, I don't actually think are because we actually want to do them or we feel like they'll make us happy. you know, taking internships, applying for jobs that are going to pay us little and require more hours than we want to give, you know, of course there are some opportunities that are just incredible and we should definitely leap at. But a lot of the time, the path that we are on has in some way been selected for us by those around us and by society. And it feels really natural to
任何没有这么做的人都是在假装。老实说，我真的这么认为。其次，我们做出的许多关于职业、工作和专业生活的决定，其实并不符合我们真正想做的事情，或者我们觉得它们能让我们快乐。你知道，接受实习，申请那些付给我们微薄薪水却要求比我们愿意付出的时间还要多的工作（当然，有些机会简直不可思议，我们绝对应该抓住），但在很多情况下，我们所走的道路在某种程度上是由我们周围的人和由社会为我们选择的。顺从现状和大家都在做的事情感觉非常自然，
go along with the status quo and what everyone else is doing, even when that might actually make us unhappy. And third, in this amazing huge world, there is always going to be someone who is doing more than you, making more money than you, that is better at their job than you, smarter than you, or at least it seems that way from their facade and from their LinkedIn. But all of that really doesn't matter. It really doesn't matter. If you're feeling behind right now, feeling a bit lost, feeling a bit stuck at a crossroads, or maybe you're just simply unhappy with what you're doing. I just want to remind you, and I will remind you again, society has repeatedly told us a narrative since childhood, and especially in Western cultures, that work is way more than it ever should be,
哪怕这实际上可能会让我们不快乐。第三，在这个奇妙的巨大世界里，总会有人做得比你多，赚得比你多，工作比你做得好，比你聪明，或者至少从他们的外表和领英上看是这样的。但所有这些其实都并不重要。这真的不重要。如果你现在觉得落后，觉得有点迷失，觉得卡在了十字路口，或者也许你只是对你正在做的事情不满意。我只是想提醒你，而且我会再次提醒你：自童年以来，社会一再向我们灌输一种叙事，尤其是在西方文化中，那就是工作比以往任何时候都更重要，
that status and appearing successful are going to make us happier. But time and time again, across an ever-increasing body of research, we can see that work and employment are really not the only drivers of our happiness, but they can still cause us, you know, really significant anxiety. And it's a, it's a really strange paradox. The thing that doesn't actually tend to bring us the greatest happiness can also bring us some of the greatest struggle and the greatest stress. Based on this survey from Anxiety Disorders Association of America, whilst only about 9% of individuals are living with a diagnosed anxiety disorder, something like general anxiety disorder or a phobia,
地位和显得成功会让我们更快乐。但一次又一次，越来越多的研究表明，工作和就业确实不是我们快乐的唯一驱动力，但它们仍然会给我们带来……你知道的，非常显著的焦虑。这是一个……这是一个非常奇怪的矛盾。那个实际上并不能给我们带来最大快乐的东西，也可能给我们带来最大的挣扎和最大的压力。根据美国焦虑症协会（Anxiety Disorders Association of America）的一项调查，虽然只有大约9%的人患有确诊的焦虑症，比如广泛性焦虑症或某种恐惧症，
40% of people will experience ongoing stress or anxiety in their daily life that is associated purely with their work or their careers. During this episode, if my preamble hasn't given it away, we are going to talk about more than just work anxiety or career anxiety, which is anxiety that's specifically associated with the jobs we're doing now. But I thought that this type of concern and some of the experiences that come along with it might be a really good place to start because they really do have applicability across a spectrum of worries that we're going to be discussing.
但有40%的人会在日常生活中经历持续的压力或焦虑，而这纯粹与他们的工作或职业有关。在这一集里，如果我的开场白还没有透露的话，我们将讨论的不仅仅是工作焦虑或职业焦虑——也就是专门与我们目前正在做的工作相关的焦虑。但我认为这种类型的担忧以及随之而来的一些经历可能是个很好的起点，因为它们确实适用于我们要讨论的各种各样的忧虑。
And if you're someone who is experiencing anxiety and even, you know, maybe a level of distress that's specifically associated with performing your tasks at your job, attending your job, or going into work, you might feel symptoms that are very similar to an anxiety disorder. And symptoms that might be interrupting your life and making you feel quite awful. You know, taking an unusual amount of time off, that is such a huge indicator that you might be dissatisfied with your work. Focusing too much on the negative aspects of your job, struggling to complete tasks or overreacting, worrying too much.
如果你是一个正在经历焦虑，甚至……你知道的，可能达到一定程度痛苦的人，而这种痛苦专门与履行工作任务、参加工作或去上班有关，你可能会感到与焦虑症非常相似的症状。这些症状可能会打断你的生活，让你感觉相当糟糕。你知道，请异常多的假，这绝对是一个巨大的指标，表明你可能对你的工作不满意。过度关注工作中的负面消极方面，挣扎着完成任务或过度反应，过度担心。
You might also feel a lot of anticipatory anxiety before you go to work. And just a general sense of fatigue. Like something isn't right. Insomnia, an exaggerated startle reaction, not being able to catch a breath. I think if you have ever worked a job, you've hated or been in a work environment that was hostile, unpleasant, you know, had really high stakes. These experiences, these symptoms might be very common to you, might be something. something that you know a lot about. For example, I used to work at this steak restaurant when I was at
在上班前，你可能也会感到很多预期性焦虑。以及一种普遍的疲劳感。就像有什么不对劲一样。失眠，夸张的惊跳反应，喘不上气。我想如果你曾做过一份你痛恨的工作，或者身处一个充满敌意、令人不快、你知道的、风险很高的工作环境中，这些经历、这些症状对你来说可能非常熟悉，可能是你非常了解的事情。例如，我在
uni. Yes, I'm a woman of many hats. And it became such an unpleasant environment and was so awful and just like exhausting and draining that the few weeks before I quit, I think I must have called in sick at least three to four times. And it's a really natural way of of coping with anxiety. It's a really normal coping mechanism when something is. unpleasant. It's avoidance. We're avoiding the thing in this case work that makes us feel uncomfortable and that's supernatural to do. And when you're avoiding work, I think that's a really clear sign that you're probably not very happy. You're probably not fulfilled or respected. And it's time for a change. There's something in you that's really saying, hey, like this isn't for us.
大学时曾在一家牛排馆工作。是的，我是个身兼多职的女性。那里的环境变得如此令人不愉快，是如此糟糕、精疲力竭且消耗心力，以至于在我辞职前的几个星期里，我想我至少请了三四次病假。这是应对焦虑的一种非常自然的方式。当某事令人不快时，这是一种非常正常的应对机制。这就是逃避。我们在逃避那件让我们感到不舒服的事情（在这种情况下是工作），这样做是再自然不过了。当你逃避工作时，我认为这是一个非常明确的信号，表明你可能并不是很高兴。你可能没有获得成就感或受到尊重。是时候做出改变了。你内心深处有些东西在呼喊：“嘿，这不适合我们。”
I know this is what's expected of us. I know I have these conflicting feelings about why I'm here. But maybe this environment isn't for me and maybe I would be better able to learn somewhere else. When we talk about anxiety that is associated with work and our careers, there are these two other types of anxiety that I think are really important to talk about and which don't really seem to get much attention or the attention that I think they deserve. And these two types of anxiety that may incur in relation to our careers and our professional lives are learning anxiety and survival anxiety. And these types of anxiety, they act in tandem to either motivate us to stay or to leave a job or a career path.
我知道这是对我们的期望。我知道我对为什么来这里有着这些矛盾的感受。但也许这个环境不适合我，也许我在别的地方能更好地学习。当我们谈论与工作和职业相关的焦虑时，还有另外两种类型的焦虑，我认为也非常重要，值得探讨，但它们似乎并没有得到太多关注，或者说没有得到我认为它们应得的关注。这两种可能与我们的职业和专业生活相关的焦虑是：学习焦虑和生存焦虑。这两种焦虑，它们共同作用，要么激励我们留下，要么激励我们离开一份工作或职业道路。
They're kind of these inbuilt reactions that's really directed towards the environments that we're most often in and especially our work environments. So I'm going to explain them a little bit now. And while I do, I want you to think about the situation you might be struggling with and how this might apply. So firstly, we have learning anxiety. And this comes from being afraid to try something new out of fear that it's going to be too difficult, that we're going to look stupid, that will have to apart from old habits, that it's going to be uncomfortable. And learning anxiety is what might stop you when you think about starting a new role,
它们有点像那种内置的反应，直接指向我们最常身处的环境，尤其是我们的工作环境。所以我现在将稍微解释一下它们。在我解释的同时，我想让你想想你可能正在挣扎的情况以及这如何适用。首先，我们有学习焦虑。这来自于害怕尝试新事物，因为担心它会太困难，担心我们会出丑，担心我们必须改掉旧习惯，担心它会让人不舒服。当你考虑开始一个新角色时，学习焦虑可能会阻碍你，
when you think about leaving a toxic work environment. You know, you're going to have to learn something new. You're going to have to meet new people. You might not be great at it. You might not have those solid relationships to begin with. It's the fear that arises when you realize you're, you know, you might have to take a risk to change your path and to achieve the goals that are related to your career and your professional life.
当你考虑离开一个有毒的工作环境时。你知道，你将不得不学习新东西。你将不得不认识新的人。你可能不擅长它。一开始你可能没有那些牢固的关系。当你意识到你……你知道的，你可能不得不冒险改变你的道路来实现与你的职业和专业生活相关的目标时，这种恐惧就会产生。
And it might not go perfectly. But on the flip side, we have survival anxiety. And that is this horrible sometimes, not always, but no, normally unpleasant realization that if you want to make it, maybe not that that's not the right phrase, but if you really want to do something that you love, if you really want to be in control of your career and your professional life, you're probably going to have to make a change. And this anxiety is what propels you to maybe look for a new job in the first place. it's that feeling of I actually really need to get out of here because if I don't do it now,
而且事情可能不会进行得那么完美。但在另一面，我们有生存焦虑。这是一种可怕的、有时（并非总是，但通常是）令人不快的认识：如果你想成功（也许这不是正确的短语，但如果你真的想做你热爱的事情，如果你真的想掌控你的职业和专业生活），你可能不得不做出改变。这种焦虑正是促使你可能一开始就去寻找新工作的动力。那是那种“我真的需要离开这里，因为如果我现在不这么做，
maybe I'll never leave. I'm just going to fade away. I'm going to be, you know, another fly on the wall at this workplace. And it's the feeling, the anxious feeling that tells you it's really time to move on to something else. You know, I think another word for it is restless feet. Like it's survival. It's like, you know, we've exhausted this resource. It's time to move on. So when your survival anxiety becomes a stronger force than, you know, it's a stronger force than your learning anxiety when your desire to kind of move on and move upward is stronger than that fear of failing and that fear of trying something new and maybe not getting it right. I think that's when you're in the right place where you are probably ready to move on.
也许我永远都不会离开。我只会逐渐黯淡。我将成为这个工作场所里又一只墙上的苍蝇”的感觉。这是一种焦虑的感觉，它告诉你真的是时候转向其他事情了。你知道，我想另一个词是“脚底抹油，想要离开”。就像这是为了生存。就像，你知道，我们已经耗尽了这个资源。是时候前进了。所以当你的生存焦虑变成了一种比……它比你的学习焦虑更强大的力量时，当你想前进和向上发展的渴望比对失败的恐惧、对尝试新事物且可能做不对的恐惧更强烈时，我认为这就是你处于正确位置的时候，你可能已经准备好前进了。
It's time to look for a new job or consider a career shift. And this example of that feeling of the push and pull of staying or leaving, you know, an unhappy workplace or an unsatisfying job, is such an important crosswords, I think we all experience at some point. I'm sure most of you, you know, for most of you, it is an experience you probably may have had. I don't think I can think of anyone who has stayed in their job, you know, their first job for their entire life, unless you're like a nun or something. And even if you're technically performing the same role, like you're a barista or a doctor,
是时候寻找新工作或考虑职业转型了。这种关于留下来还是离开——一个不快乐的工作场所或一个令人不满职位的推拉之感的例子，是一个如此重要的十字路口，我认为我们所有人都会在某个时刻经历。我确信你们大多数人，你知道，对于你们大多数人来说，这可能是你经历过的事。我想我想不出有谁会在他们的工作中待上一辈子，比如他们的第一份工作，除非你是个修女之类的。而且即使你在技术上执行相同的角色，比如你是一名咖啡师或医生，
we all need a change in environment. You know, humans get bored really easily. and our motivations and our desires change just as frequently. So if an environment or if a job or a career path even isn't suiting you right now, what's stopping you from changing? You know, there are always going to be financial pressures and other things that we need to consider, but there is also agency. You really are in control and you get to decide what environments feed your soul,
我们都需要改变环境。你知道，人类很容易感到厌倦，我们的动机和欲望也同样频繁地发生变化。所以如果一个环境、一份工作甚至是一条职业道路现在不适合你，是什么在阻止你改变呢？你知道，总会有财务压力和我们需要考虑的其他事情，但也有自主权。你真的掌握着主控权，你可以决定什么样的环境能够滋养你的灵魂，
what skills you get to learn, what opportunities you get to have. So I imagine for some of you listening, you are at this very crossroads right now. Maybe you've been at uni for a couple of years and you're like, fuck, I actually really don't like this course. I don't like this, you know, what I'm learning. I don't actually think it's for me. That can be really scary. But once that learning anxiety overcome, you know, once the survival anxiety, sorry,
你可以学习什么技能，获得什么机会。所以我想对于你们中的一些听众来说，你们现在正处于这个十字路口。也许你上大学已经几年了，然后你想：“靠，我其实真的不喜欢这门课程。”我不喜欢这个……你知道的，我正在学的东西。我其实觉得它不适合我。这可能会让人非常害怕。但一旦克服了那种学习焦虑……你知道的，一旦生存焦虑，抱歉，
overcomes your learning anxiety. You're really able to ask yourself, you know, what is the worst case scenario here? Do you know, do the benefits outweigh the costs? Why am I fearful of this change? Is it because it would disappoint others? Is it because I'm worried about not being comfortable? Because if your answer is yes to those last few questions, I think, you know, the reason why you're staying is perhaps not the right one.
克服了你的学习焦虑。你真的能够问自己，你知道，这里最坏的情况是什么？你知道，收益大于成本吗？为什么我害怕这种改变？是因为它会让人失望吗？是因为我担心无法保持舒适吗？因为如果你对最后几个问题的回答是“是”，我想，你知道，你留下的原因可能并不是正确的。
So I'm going to take a little break here. because I want to talk about our next partner on the show. Our next partner has a product that I've been using quite literally every day for the past few months. So I started taking AG1 for a number of reasons. So if you are an avid listener of podcasts, such as myself, you may have heard of this brand. It's called Athletic Greens. And I had been getting recommendations for this constantly. And I really wanted to see what the hype was about.
所以我在这里稍微休息一下，因为我想谈谈我们节目的下一个合作伙伴。我们的下一个合作伙伴有一款产品，我在过去几个月里字面意义上每天都在使用。我开始服用AG1有几个原因。所以如果你是一个像我一样的播客狂热听众，你可能听说过这个品牌。它叫做Athletic Greens（运动绿源）。我一直不断听到关于这个产品的推荐。我真的很想看看它到底有什么好 hype（被热议）的。
I've also been, you know, trying to eat better for my body and my mind these past few months. It's been a stressful few months. And this seemed like a pretty easy way to do it. So, okay, maybe I should explain what it is. What is agey one? It's essentially a nutritional insurance. So you take one little scoop. I normally take mine in the morning before I have breakfast.
在过去的几个月里，我也一直在……你知道的，为了我的身体和心灵尝试吃得更好。这几个月压力很大。这似乎是一个相当简单的方法。所以，好吧，也许我应该解释一下它是什么。什么是AG1？它本质上是一份营养保险。所以你只需要取一小勺。我通常在吃早餐前的早晨服用。
And you essentially receive all of the vitamins and minerals you might need for the day. It's great for your nervous system. It's great for your immune system, your immune system, your air. energy levels, your focus, all things I think we kind of want in our 20s and when we're young and we want our bodies to be healthy and energized. My housemate is also now really obsessed with it, so I'm going to need to stock up soon. But essentially, it's a great addition for your health. It supports mental clarity. It helps me sleep better. And it's a really kind of easy thing to add to your lifestyle. It's a small micro habit that is one extra thing you can do on your day to take care
你基本上能摄取当天可能需要的所有维生素和矿物质。这对你的神经系统很好。这对你的免疫系统、免疫系统、你的……能量水平、专注力都很好，所有这些我认为我们在20年代时都会想要的东西，当我们年轻，我们希望我们的身体保持健康和充满活力。我的室友现在也对它非常着迷，所以我很快就需要囤货了。但本质上，它是你健康的绝佳补充。它支持心理清晰度。它帮助我睡得更好。而且这是一种非常……融入生活方式的简单事情。这是一个微小的小习惯，是你一天中可以做的额外事情之一，用来照顾
of yourself, which I imagine is probably a priority for all of us. Also, in keeping with the ethos of this podcast, it is planet-friendly, it's people-friendly, athletic greens, is a climate-neutral certified company. Thank you very much. And regularly gives back to the community, which I think is important for really any brand that talks about health. We obviously care about our own well-being, but it's great to be supported by a company that cares about the world as well. So today, I think, is a great time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a really super convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop mixed with water or juice or whatever.
你自己，我想这可能是我们所有人的首要任务。此外，秉承这个播客的精神，它是对地球友好的，对人友好的，Athletic Greens是一家气候中立认证的公司。非常感谢。并且定期回馈社区，我认为这对于任何谈论健康的品牌来说都很重要。我们显然关心我们自己的幸福，但能够得到一家同样关心世界的公司的支持，这真是太棒了。所以今天，我认为是恢复健康、用真正超级方便的日常营养武装免疫系统的大好时机。只需要一勺与水或果汁或任何东西混合，
Milk, if you want, I don't know, one scoop every day. That's it. No need for a million different supplements and vitamins to look after your health. And to make it really easy, athletic greens is going to give you a free one-year-sum. supply of immune supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash gemma. Again, that is athletic greens.com slash gemma with the J to take ownership of your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance.
如果你想的话加牛奶，我不知道，每天一勺。就是这样。不需要为了照顾健康而准备一百万种不同的补充剂和维生素。为了让它变得非常简单，Athletic Greens将为您首次购买提供一年份的免费免疫支持维生素D和五个免费旅行包。你所需要做的就是访问 athleticgreens.com/gemma。再次强调，那是 athleticgreens.com/gemma（带字母J），来掌控你的健康，并挑选终极日常营养保险吧。
Now, like many of the topics we discuss on the show, the complexities are vast and it's very hard to touch on everything we might want to discuss. But for the second half of the episode, I really want to talk about that feeling of, you know, not being where you think you should be in your career. Imposter syndrome and some of the existential dread that can accompany that, you know, that experience where your work doesn't really align with what you perceive as your high mission or your purpose. Not all of us, I think, have the luxury of being able to do what we truly love, our passion for our careers. So how can we be? we still have jobs or work that is fulfilling and maintain strong interests and how can we make
现在，就像我们在节目中讨论的许多话题一样，复杂性是巨大的，要触及我们可能想讨论的所有事情是非常困难的。但对于节目的后半部分，我真的很想谈谈那种感觉……你知道的，在你的职业生涯中没有达到你认为应该达到的水平。冒名顶替综合症（Imposter syndrome）以及可能随之而来的一些存在主义恐惧，那种体验——你的工作实际上并不符合你所认为的高尚使命或目标。我想我们并不是所有人都有奢侈去做我们真正热爱的事情，也就是我们职业的热情所在。那么我们如何才能……
sure that the things that are happening in our professional lives and the anxieties that we might be feeling there are things that we can manage and reinforce that idea that we repeat time and time again throughout this episode that work is not your life? I think that that final point of imposter syndrome and of the idea of comparing success is, and then I'm really excited to discuss. For those of you who know this podcast is not my job, at least it's not my full-time job. I actually work full-time as a health consultant.
我们仍然可以拥有充实的工作，保持强烈的兴趣，并且我们如何能够确保在我们的职业生活中发生的事情以及我们在那里可能感受到的焦虑是我们能够管理的，并强化我们在整个节目中一再重复的那个观点：工作不是你的生活？我认为冒名顶替综合症的最后一点以及比较成功的想法是……我真的很兴奋能进行讨论。对于那些知道这个播客不是我的工作——至少不是我的全职工作——的人来说。我实际上全职工作是一名健康顾问。
So that kind of balancing act between feeding myself and feeling confident at work and still feeling, you know, feeding my soul is one that I think I've gotten much better at over the years and that I'm really excited to talk about. I think so often in our 20s, we are young, we're still learning and we're so worried that we're not achieving enough or doing enough or that we're not on the right path. So how do we overcome that feeling? It's such a messy feeling. It's an uncomfortable feeling and it really is based in social comparison. I think the main
所以，这种在养活自己、在工作中感到自信以及依然感觉……你知道的，滋养灵魂之间的平衡，是我觉得这些年来我已经做得好得多的一点，我也非常兴奋能谈论这一点。我想在我们的20年代，我们常常很年轻，我们仍在学习，我们非常担心自己没有取得足够的成就，或者做得不够，或者我们没有走在正确的道路上。那么我们如何克服这种感觉呢？这是一种非常混乱的感觉。这是一种不舒服的感觉，它确实建立在社会比较的基础上。我认为主要的
thing I like to remind myself is that success is really relative. It's subjective. You know, it is in our human nature to define ourselves in terms of others. We know who we are by a comparing ourselves to what others are doing and seeing the differences, both negative and positive, especially role models or people that we see as kind of poster children or poster people of success. And though the negative comparisons are definitely a lot easier to remember, I think it's also important to understand that a lot of us have achieved more than, you know, we ever could have fathomed or we're ever capable of giving ourselves credit for. And the truth is that comparing ourselves to others and shores that we never feel successful.
我想提醒自己的是，成功其实是相对的。它是主观的。你知道，用他人来定义自己是我们的天性。我们通过将自己与他人所做的事情进行比较并看到差异来了解自己，无论是消极的还是积极的，尤其是榜样或那些我们视为成功海报儿童或海报人物的人。虽然消极的比较肯定更容易记住，但我认为同样重要的是要明白，我们中的许多人取得的成就比……你知道的，我们曾经想象过的或者我们能给自己记功的还要多。事实是，将自己与他人进行比较，确保了我们永远不会觉得自己成功。
We have to instead measure our goals and our progress to the past instead of someone else's present. We, you know, aren't actually in the same race. No two people are ever going to be the same. And instead of looking around and being like, okay, they're further ahead than me, they're further ahead of me, you know, they're doing that. They've got that internship. Am I doing the thing that I love? Why does everyone else seem happier than me? Take a step back. Just sit for a second and realize how far you've come. You know, I always like to picture myself when I was five. Like my five-year-old self would never have imagined that I was doing this or that I was, you know, working at my other job and having a great time and producing things for the community and
我们必须转而将我们的目标和进展与过去进行衡量，而不是与别人的现在进行衡量。我们，你知道的，实际上并不在同一场比赛中。没有两个人是完全相同的。不要环顾四周，然后想：“好吧，他们比我领先，他们比我领先，你知道，他们在做那个。他们得到了那个实习机会。我在做我热爱的事吗？为什么其他人看起来比我更快乐？”退后一步。坐下来一会儿，意识到你已经走了多远。你知道，我总是喜欢想象自己五岁时的样子。我五岁时的自己绝对不会想象到我在做这个，或者我在……你知道的，在做我的另一份工作，玩得很开心，为社区生产东西，
for society. So I think that's a much better motivator. Think about where you've come from, not where other people are going. I think another way to kind of overcome that sense that our successes, you know, are never going to be big enough that our career isn't taking off, that we're not doing the right thing, is to celebrate our small wins. I think if we stop celebrating the small things, eventually all we see is failure. It's really not that often that big, amazing victories kind of come around. And if we wait for those big, amazing, like, amazing celebratory moments, it might be a while. It might be a while between those. So it's really important to celebrate the small winds and every step closer you get to whatever dream you have, every time you do something
为社会生产东西。所以我觉得这是一个更好的动力。想想你从哪里来，而不是别人要去哪里。我认为克服这种“我们的成功永远不够大、我们的职业没有起色、我们没有做正确的事情”的感觉的另一种方法，是庆祝我们的小胜利。我认为如果我们停止庆祝小事，最终我们看到的只有失败。重大、惊人的胜利并不经常降如果我们等待那些重大、惊人的庆祝时刻，可能需要一段时间。这些时刻之间可能会隔一段时间。所以庆祝小胜以及你离任何梦想更近的每一步都非常重要，每次你把事情做得
a little bit better, you have a realization about what you really want, you know, go back to study, you do really well in an essay. And I would really kind of recommend, I think I say this on most of my episodes, like the absolute power of journaling and keeping track of where you were in the past and where you are now and kind of seeing how far that we have come. And it's a really great way to no longer make those comparisons between ourselves and other people when it comes to our work lives and our professional lives. And I think let's link, I think really very much linked to this is forgetting to look back and forgetting to understand how our dreams change over time. Yes, obviously we can look back at our younger selves and be like, oh, look how far we've come.
稍微好一点，你对你真正想要的东西有了认识，你知道，回去学习，你在写文章时做得很好。我真的会推荐……我想我在我的大多数节目中都说过这一点……绝对要相信写日记的力量，记录你在过去的位置和现在的样子，并看看我们已经走过了多远。这是一个非常好的方法，可以不再在我们工作生活和职业生活中进行我们自己和他人之间的比较。而且我认为这与……我认为与此密切相关的是忘记回顾过去，忘记理解我们的梦想是如何随时间改变的。是的，很明显我们可以回顾年轻时的自己，然后说：“哦，看看我们走了多远。”
but I also want you to think about what did you want to do when you were 12 or when you were 15 or 16 or 17 or 22 or if you're a bit later in your 20s what about 25 like things change our desires change and it's totally okay for you to switch around and to try new things something a friend said to me once which really stuck with me is this idea of the paradox of comparison for someone else you're actually living their dream life right now what you have achieved is their idea of success. And whilst you're busy comparing yourself to others, there's someone else who's looking at you thinking you're absolutely amazing. And we've mentioned this with the social comparison theory at the beginning, but we really are hardwired
但我也想让你想想，你在12岁、15岁、16岁、17岁或22岁时想做什么，或者如果你在20多岁稍晚一点，25岁时呢？事物在变，我们的欲望在变，你完全可以四处转换并尝试新事物。一个朋友曾经对我说过的一句话深深触动了我，那就是比较的悖论这个想法：对别人来说，你现在实际上正在过着他们梦想中的生活。你所取得的成就正是他们对成功的看法。正当你忙于将自己与他人进行比较时，还有另一个人看着你，认为你绝对太棒了。我们在节目开始时通过社会比较理论提到了这一点，但我们确实是天生就……
to compare our professional actions and our professional and career accomplishments and successes to others. And that makes sense. It really does make sense. It allows us to understand our place in society. And sometimes we can be very competitive and our own able to appreciate where we are by looking at others. But it actually sometimes helps to understand that there are people who would look up to you just as much as you look up to others. This perspective is actually called downward social comparison whereby, this is a scientific definition. So take it with a grain of salt. But downward social comparison occurs when we compare ourselves to others who we perceive as being worse off than us. I don't like that term worse off because I don't think
将我们的职业行动、职业和职业成就以及成功与他人进行比较。这很有意义。确实很有意义。它使我们能够了解自己在社会中的地位。有时我们会有很强的竞争意识，通过观察他人来认清自己的位置。但实际上，有时明白有些人对你的仰慕不亚于你对他人的仰慕，会对我们有所帮助。这种观点实际上被称为向下社会比较，这是一个科学定义，所以大家听听就好。但向下社会比较发生在我们将自己与那些我们认为不如自己的人进行比较时。我不喜欢“不如”这个词，因为我认为
anyone is ever worse off. You know, we're alive, we're breathing, we are loved, how can that be bad? But people who maybe a few steps behind where we are, who want to be where we are. And obviously we want to dispel the idea of social comparison altogether, but sometimes that can be a comforting thought to imagine yourself as someone else's hero, as someone else's inspiration. I also want to talk about imposter syndrome. Okay, so some fun psychology of your 20s trivia for you. The psychology of imposter syndrome was actually the first episode. I ever put out on this show, which seemed really fitting at the time. So if this topic is really interesting to you, please feel free to go and listen to that and, you know, also hear exactly
没有人会真正不如别人。你知道，我们活着，我们呼吸着，我们被爱着，怎么会糟糕呢？但那些可能比我们落后几步、想要达到我们所处位置的人。很显然，我们想要彻底消除社会比较的想法，但有时，把自己想象成别人的英雄、别人的灵感，会是一种安慰。我还想谈谈冒名顶替综合征。好吧，给你们讲点有趣的20多岁心理学冷知识。关于冒名顶替综合征心理学的节目，其实是我在这个节目中发布的第一期，当时觉得非常贴切。所以如果这个话题真的很吸引你，请随时去收听那一期，并且，你也知道，还可以听听
how far this show has come, particularly in audio quality, I will say. But aside from that, imposter syndrome can really go hand in hand with career anxiety in so many ways. The phrase imposter syndrome, it refers to a feeling very similar to social comparison, but I think a lot more severe. it involves feelings of self-doubt and incompetence, that we're bad at our jobs, that we don't know what we're doing, that we're failing, that we should have it more together. And this feeling persists despite all the available evidence pointing to the fact that you are indeed very accomplished and very incredible and highly skilled. And the fact that you've made so much progress in the past, you know, I don't know how long, but since you were a child or since you graduated high school, like the things that you've done must have been amazing to get you to where you are. imposter syndrome is such a common experience amongst people I've spoken to, especially as we're starting out in our chosen field and we're trying to get our footing. Perhaps you're listening to this and you're in your first full-time job or your first internship or your first placement.
这个节目取得了多大的进步，尤其是在音质方面，我必须得说。但除此之外，冒名顶替综合征在很多方面确实都与职业焦虑息息相关。“冒名顶替综合征”这个词，指的是一种与社会比较非常相似、但我认为要严重得多的感觉。它包含自我怀疑和无能的感觉，觉得我们工作做得很糟，不知道自己在做什么，觉得我们在失败，觉得我们本该表现得更好。尽管所有现有的证据都表明你实际上非常有成就、非常出色且技能高超，但这种感觉依然挥之不去。而且，你在过去——我不知道是多久，但从你还是个孩子的时候起，或者从你高中毕业起——取得了那么大的进步，你所做的事情一定很了不起，才能让你走到今天。冒名顶替综合征是我交谈过的人中非常普遍的一种体验，尤其是当我们刚开始涉足自己选择的领域、试图站稳脚跟的时候。也许你正在听这期节目，而你正处于你的第一份全职工作、第一份实习或第一个实习岗位中。
And it can be a huge source of career anxiety to not really know what you're doing, to not know if this is what you want. And it prompts some of those very existential questions of do I belong here? is this the right choice for me do i actually care about this can i do this and the chances are the answer to all of those questions is yes but our minds have this tricky way of priming us to expect the worst and to tear ourselves down an imposter syndrome especially in our professional and working lives has been described as the silent career killer i'm just going to say that again i love this phrase the silent career killer. Those experiencing imposter syndrome have such an intense sense of inadequacy, even when told otherwise, that sometimes we can self-sabotage and we can give up on things
不知道自己在做什么，不知道这是否是你想要的，这可能会成为职业焦虑的巨大来源。它引发了一些非常存在主义的问题：我属于这里吗？这是对的选择吗？我真的在乎这个吗？我能做到吗？而这些问题的答案大概率都是“是的”。但我们的思维有一种狡猾的方式，它会让我们预作最坏的打算，并自我贬低。冒名顶替综合征，尤其是在我们的职业和工作生活中，被称为“无声的职业杀手”。我要再重复一遍，我很喜欢这个短语——“无声的职业杀手”。那些经历冒名顶替综合征的人会产生一种强烈的无能感，即使别人告诉他们并非如此，有时我们也会自我设限。由于这种自我怀疑，因为我们觉得自己是个骗子，因为我们觉得自己——你知道——没有达到应有的水平，我们不属于这里，我们在尝试之前就已经
before we've even given it a go because of that self-doubt, because we feel like a fraud, because we feel like, you know, we're not where we should be that we don't belong here. All of these mental phenomenon we have spoken about when we're talking about career anxiety are such a complicated cocktail of experiences and it's so hard to break them down because I think whilst all of us might feel a little bit of apprehension about where we are in our professional lives it can manifest in such a different way for everyone but all of them can really leave us feeling uneasy like we're heading down the wrong path so once again I want to remind you of that one crucial lesson that I want all of you to take away from this episode your job your
放弃了。当我们谈论职业焦虑时，我们所讨论的所有这些心理现象都是一种复杂的体验鸡尾酒，很难将其剖析开来。因为我认为，虽然我们所有人对自己在职业生涯中的处境都可能会感到一丝担忧，但它在每个人身上的表现形式可能会截然不同。不过，所有这些确实都会让我们感到不安，就像我们正走上一条错误的道路一样。所以，我再次想提醒大家那个至关重要的教训，我希望你们所有人都能从这期节目中领悟到这一点：你的工作、你的
career and what you do for work is not the most important thing about you. Indeed, it's probably not even the top three. Think about all the other things that make you who you are and contribute to a happy, brilliant life, the relationships and love you create, how you treat others, your family, your health, your hobbies and passions, your mission, your memories, you know, moments of profound happiness. All those things sound a lot more important. to me than whether you're ahead of, you know, Nancy on LinkedIn or, you know, whether this job is really what you want. So if you are experiencing career anxiety at the moment and wondering if you are where you should be, take a breath and remind yourself that this is not the end of your story.
职业以及你所从事的事情并不是关于你最重要的东西。事实上，它可能连前三名都排不上。想想所有其他造就了你、并为你带来快乐而精彩的生活的事物：你建立的人际关系和爱、你对待他人、家人、健康、爱好和激情的方式、你的使命、你的记忆，你知道的，那些深刻幸福的时刻。在我看来，所有这些事情都比你是否领先于——你知道的——领英上的南希，或者这份工作是否真的是你想要的，要重要得多。因此，如果你目前正在经历职业焦虑，并想知道自己是否身处正确的轨道，请深吸一口气，提醒自己，这并不是你故事的结局。
You can change paths at any point and the most amazing opportunities. They really do, you know, show up when we least expect them. And I promise you, you're not failing. I promise you that. In fact, I'm sure no one else thinks that either and if you're having a hard time adapting, maybe this is a learning experience that you will grow from and adapt to until it's time for the next challenge. Society, especially in this day and age, has become so focused on work and our careers and our success over life. But work is not the content of a happy life, it's just an element. And sometimes it can be really useful to take a step back, like I said, compare. where you are now to where you were in the past,
你可以在任何时候改变道路，而最惊人的机会确实会在我们最意想不到的时候出现。我向你保证，你并没有失败。我向你保证。事实上，我确信也没有其他人会这么想。如果你在适应方面遇到了困难，也许这是一次学习经历，你将从中成长并适应，直到迎接下一个挑战的时刻到来。社会，尤其是在当今这个时代，变得太过于关注工作、职业和生活中的成功。但工作并不是幸福生活的全部，它只是其中一个要素。正如我所说，有时退一步，将你现在的处境
recognize those small successes, think deeply about what your dreams actually are and put your thoughts down, maybe even a little plan onto the page. Our brains are a lot better at organizing smaller, bite-sized thoughts and steps rather than massive, complicated problems we feel we're never going to be able to digest. And sometimes career anxiety is exactly that,
与过去的自己进行比较，承认那些微小的成功，深入思考你的梦想究竟是什么，并将你的想法——甚至是一个小计划——写在纸上，真的会非常有用。我们的大脑更擅长整理较小的、一口大小的想法和步骤，而不是那些我们觉得永远无法消化的巨大而复杂的问题。有时，职业焦虑正是如此：
a massive, complicated anxiety that's eating away at us fed by social comparison and work anxiety and imposter syndrome, and until we're able to break it down and identify what it is we're worried about, why we don't feel like we belong, why we feel like we're behind, why we feel like we're doing it wrong, we're never really going to be able to overcome that. I promise you it is going to be all right. You're definitely where you need to be.
一个巨大的、复杂的焦虑，它正在侵蚀我们，由社会比较、工作焦虑和冒名顶替综合征共同滋养。直到我们能够将其剖析并认清我们到底在担心什么、为什么我们觉得自己不属于这里、为什么我们觉得自己落后了、为什么我们觉得自己做错了，我们才真正能够克服它。我向你保证，一切都会好起来的。你绝对身处你需要身处的地方。
And thank you for listening to this episode. It was such an interesting one to do. Some of that science is so fascinating. and definitely something that was worthwhile for me. I also want to again thank our sponsor Athletic Greens for being able to let me do what I love, which is such a great feeling. And to all of you for listening,
感谢收听本期节目。制作这期节目非常有趣。其中一些科学知识太迷人了，对我来说绝对不虚此行。我也要再次感谢我们的赞助商 Athletic Greens，让我能够做自己喜欢的事，这种感觉太棒了。感谢所有收听节目的听众，
you literally make my week every single week. It's just insane how many people want to listen to this. And I think, yeah, it really does blow my mind. So I'm so grateful. And thank you as always. I'd also invite you to follow the psychological, of your 20s on Instagram. That is where I decide what episodes to put out at the end of every week.
你们简直每周都在点亮我的生活。有这么多人想要收听这个节目，这简直太疯狂了。我想，是的，这真的让我大开眼界。我非常感激，一如既往地谢谢你们。我也想邀请大家在 Instagram 上关注 Psychological of your 20s。那是我决定每周结束时发布哪些节目的地方。
So this one was actually chosen by listeners. And there will be another poll next week. So vote away and I will produce the content and it will be in your feed. And thank you again for listening. I hope you have a lovely, lovely day. On the Look Back at it podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
所以这一期其实是听众们选出来的。下周还会有一个投票，所以大家尽管去投票吧，我会制作相应的内容，它就会出现在你们的动态里。再次感谢大家的收听。希望你们度过美好、美好的一天。欢迎收听 Look Back at it 播客。1979年，对我来说那是个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利西。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的 Learn the Hard Way。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的有执照的专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套精神盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。